monsieur paul meurisse est mort vers la
liberté des prix à la sncf le service
public en question manifestation monstre
à téhéran
pour l'ayatollah khomeini monsieur
bonsoir un grand seigneur nous a tiré sa
révérence ce matin pour le meurice est
mort à 66 ans terrassé par une crise
cardiaque
et ce à l'issue d'une crise d'asthme en
son domicile de nuit paul meurisse sera
presque mort en scène hier soir encore
il jouait mon père avait raison de sacha
guitry sur la scène du théâtre hébertot
c'était la 100e représentation n'y aura
pas de cent unième les grilles du
théâtre resteront fermés ce soir
et la semaine prochaine ils étaient
distingués au teint inquiétant grand
amateur d'ambiguïté entre l'autorité le
charme et le coca
prêtre policiers espions juge ou truands
du monocle aux gitans en passant par les
diaboliques marie octobre ou le déjeuner
sur l'herbe
le cinéma lui aura donné 80 rôle et
autant de succès pourtant c'est au
théâtre qu'il se réaliser pleinement
on se souvient des créations de
l'hurluberlu d'anouilh du sale égoïste
de françoise dorin de dominos de marcel
achard mais aussi de son passage à la
comédie française et de ses
interprétations de coriolan et jules
césar
il était chevalier de la maison
d'honneur mais les distinctions ne l'ont
jamais privé son sens de l'humour
comment pouvez-vous nous expliquer votre
présence dans un cirque et il n'y a pas
ici de commandes entre eux marc je ne
suis absolument pas influencé comme vous
pouvez le constater par les personnages
que j'incarne à l'écran c'est simplement
un numéro de tirs que je suis en tir de
précision
bien entendu que le suis en train de
mettre au point pour le gala de l'union
des artistes qui a lieu le 12 mars
numéro de tir
il est au point il se présente pas mal
je suis malheureusement obligés de tirer
sur des cibles telles que des ballons de
baudruche ou des fleurs parce que je
n'ai pas rencontré encore de d'acteurs
qui soient des partenaires valable
veulent pas servir de cible humaine
c'est une tout petit peu de l'acheter ça
n'est pas grave vous de nous avoir
imposé un monde que vous n'avez pas plus
envie de robert par bon pour les os de
lénine le romantisme ne va pas avec mon
visage alors donc on me devais de
tournai déroule un peu dur et bonjour
pourquoi pas si je devais mourir je
préférerais que ce soit en scène
je suis un plateau mais comme je n'ai
pas l'intention de mourir tout de suite
eh bien ça nous laisse le choix quand
même d'été possibilité que je souhaite
le plus tardive possible
vous savez la discrétion ne compte pas
dans notre métier en réalité où je sais
pas qu'on veut voir que ceux ci ont fait
ça dans un salon à partir de ce moment
là on n'est plus des on est plus
professionnel on est amateur
nous ne pouvons pas être des amateurs
puisque je l' ai souvent dit la
différence qui existe entre un amateur
et un professionnel c'est que l'amateur
vie pour faire ce métier et le
professionnel fait ce métier pour vivre
c'est une différence fut tout de même
assez sensible c'est charmant
l'occupation des locaux par les piquets
de grève on a si peu l'occasion de faire
connaissance il est à la cua le
saucisson ça vous dérange c'est beau les
veillées d'armes mais ça creuse
comme vous en voulez à vous d'être au
fait mal je ne serais pas permis de vous
le demander
ça nous engage à rien bien entendu le
saucisson n'engage jamais rien
le vin rouge non plus d'ailleurs
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire je dis
tout le vin rouge n'ont plus rien à rien
mais ça aime bien faire passer société
si vous voulez le public l'a plus
devenir has yoko l'acteur
ok à tous au cinéma
c'est la raison pour laquelle peut être
on a tendance étant donnée la vanité
extrême qui lie à en nous à partir du
moment où on l'a décrété comme ce
réacteur c'est qu'on est vanité
le contact direct est la récompense que
nous donne le public le soir quand ils
nous applaudissent et grisant pour bien
dire les choses telles qu'elles ont la
modestie d'un acteur ce n'est pas une
utopie c'est un mensonge
paul semblait hier tout à fait tout à
fait bien tout à fait normale ne
souffrent absolument pas est entré très
décontracté et très heureux de jouer
nous avions comme tous les soirs une
salle merveilleuse qu'il rendait bien
sûr très heureux et il a même à la fin
de la représentation
nous avons plaisanté ensemble était
parfaitement normal et bien entendu rien
ne laissait prévoir l'horrible chose qui
est arrivé ce matin paul paul meurisse
était un très grand acteur ça vous le
savez tous mais je voudrais signaler que
c'était un très grand professionnel
d'une intégrité parfaite et c'est pas
c'est pas souvent le cas il était un
perfectionniste et il adorait son métier
il le faisait dans la dans la joie et
avec le plaisir d'avoir accompli une
belle chose une bonne chose
manuel mais cela dernière partenaires de
paul maurice dont j'ai eu à l'apprendre
qu'il venait de terminer un livre de
souvenirs il venait de terminer cette
semaine mais les obsèques de paul
meurisse auront lieu mardi à 11 heures
en l'église saint-pierre de neuilly et
ce soir antenne de rendre à sa manière
un dernier hommage aux grands comédiens
en diffusant dans le cadre du ciné-club
l'éducation amoureuse de valentin est un
film de jean l'hôte est l'un des
derniers films de paul meurisse ceci
donc aux alentours de 23h et à la place
de la grande ville qui sera diffusée un
peu plus tard la lorraine la lorraine
grogne encore ce soir il ya d'abord la
poursuite de l'occupation des locaux du
fisc à longwy
il ya aussi la préparation d'une action
d'envergure de l'intersyndicale de ce
bassin pour lundi il ya surtout le
sentiment confus d'injustice les
lorrains se sentent pour la plupart
oublié par les grandes mesures
gouvernementales destinées à venir en
aide aux régions en difficulté et ce
sont donc des habitants des travailleurs
très inquiet très sceptique quant au
retrait les sept parlementaires qui se
sont regroupés dans une mission
d'information pour essayer de recueillir
sur place le maximum de témoignages
parlementaires de tous bords et ce fut
l'occasion pour paul amar qui les a
suivis de scruter les visages et les
interrogations des lorrains rencontrés
au hasard de son entretien
c'est un paysage digne des romans de
zola que les députés ont traversé en
trois jours un paysage triste et morne
mais auquel les lorrains restent
attachés ses cheminées ses hauts
fourneaux qui crachent leur fumée noire
c'est leur décor quotidien c'est leur
vie et ils ne veulent pas les abandonner
c'est ce qu'ils ont dit aux
parlementaires impressionné par le
climat qui règne dans la région par
cette amertume qui s'est exprimé à
longwy à thionville à homécourt et à
hagondange dernière étape de cette
mission d'information
hagondange menacé par les suppressions
d'emplois comme de nombreux aciéries au
nom de l'efficacité économique
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
députés ont voulu enquêter sur place
il s'attendait à être accueillis par les
élus de la ville
mais les grévistes de l'aciérie et elle
a eu d'aussi longs les autres centrales
demandent de quelles que vous recevez
les grévistes heures
les députés attentifs ont à leur écoute
et les métallos les habitants et
représentants syndicaux qui ont profité
de leur présence pour dire ce qu'il
ressentait et sur un taux souvent
significatif ce que de la poudre aux
yeux monsieur elle empêche monsieur du
gaspillage alors nous d'espionnage au
trio d'as et j'espère que si vous êtes
là vous serez dire aussi que dans le
rhin en colère fait allusion millions de
francs dépensés par les maîtres des
forges et ne comprend pas que les
investissements n'est plus empêcher la
suppression d'emplois sentiment partagé
par les anciens qui redoutent la
disparition de leur industrie nous les
anciens qui avons été à la source
je dirais de l'édifice à la source de
l'édifice sidérurgique dans le pays
puisque c'est à partir de nos usines
qu'on a construit des sommaires les
usinor dunkerque et autres installations
à grande capacité qu'on conserve
aujourd'hui nous nous disons que nous
avons à conserver notre part la
déception est si vive qu'elle incite les
plus modérés a lancé des avertissements
c'est le cas des cadres qui n'hésitent
plus à envisager de descendre dans la
rue et elle suivre l'exemple des plus
durs ici en lorraine
les ouvriers ont été toujours très
laborieux et ils ont défini une des
meilleure productivité de dans le
domaine industriel
alors il faut faire attention des ces
travailleurs il sent capable de
descendre dans la rue d'alimenter leur
colère voilà les témoignages que les
députés ont recueilli et qui leur ont
permis d'arriver à la même conclusion
conclusion exprimée par le docteur
rossinot un sentiment de solidarité
entre l'ensemble des personnels qui sont
concernés par ces difficultés une grande
inquiétude chez les élus locaux et la
volonté de vouloir maintenir une
capacité sidérurgique sur le terrain
tout en demandant une diversification
intense et monsieur sinon rencontrera la
semaine prochaine en dhr et shadow le
patron de la datar les ministres giroux
et boulin puis raymond barre lui même
plusieurs partis ont par ailleurs nommé
leur monsieur sidérurgie c'est par
exemple le cas au parti socialiste pour
pierre bérégovoy deux jeunes malfaiteurs
un garçon de 18 ans et une fille de 15
16 ans et renée pendant trois heures
dans une villa isolée en ardèche à
châteauneuf de vernoux après l'avoir tué
un gendarme d'europe en valois les avait
surpris en train de dévaliser une
résidence secondaire
c'est alors que le jeune le jeune homme
n'a pas hésité à tirer tuant net l'un
des deux gendarmes et je viens
d'apprendre que ces deux jeunes
meurtriers avaient échappé pour
l'instant forces de police ils ne sont
donc plus barricadé dans cette ville
mais toute façon cela ne fait qu'ajouter
à la colère des forces de l'ordre d'une
façon générale hier par exemple souvenez
vous c'était un policier abattu
froidement devant un commissariat livry
gargan près de paris
bref les policiers en ont assez ils vont
descendre dans la rue demain ils vont
défiler dans la capitale de la bastille
et la république
ce meeting était filmé il ya deux ans la
grogne des policiers s'est déjà exprimée
plusieurs fois à travers des actions
organisées par leurs syndicats mais
cette fois il ne s'agit plus seulement
de revendications sur les conditions de
travail ou l'augmentation des effectifs
c'est pour leur propre sécurité que les
gardiens de la sécurité publique vont
manifester demain de la bastille à la
préfecture de police de paris
en une semaine 14 policiers blessés l'un
d'eux a été tiré comme un lapin devant
le commissariat de livry gargan pour
rien comme ça par le caprice d'un truand
minable alors ils vont montrer leur
volonté de ne pas devenir les cibles de
cette violence que la répression seule
ne suffit pas à réduire
ils réclament des moyens la nuit ils
sont six ans seulement pour surveiller
paris
mais aussi des mesures d'ordre général
capable d'aider la police dans son rôle
de service public à l'abri de la loi et
avec la considération du citoyen ils
sont 80 mille en france 80 de 1179 il
pense que les risques du métier
désormais dépassent la mesure et à soir
sur tf1 jacques chirac s'est plaint du
climat d'insécurité il a estimé que les
désordres du week-end dernier dans le
quartier saint lazare à paris révèle
l'existence d'un certain mal de notre
temps je le cite c'est une véritable
petite révolution qui se trame à la sncf
rien de ce que je vais annoncer les
accords définitifs mais il paraît se
confirmer que l'entreprise nationale
pourrait bientôt avoir le droit de fixer
par elle même ses tarifs notamment en
matière de marchandises et même de
supprimer des lignes ou des gares ceci
parce que le gouvernement souhaite que
la sncf coûte moins cher à l'état tout
comme d'ailleurs les autres entreprises
nationalisées
alors première question la plus concrète
que va-t-il se passer pour les voyageurs
une question posée aux patrons la snc
année dans la préparation de notre
budget 79 le conseil d'administration
avait souhaité de façon à réduire le
déficit d'exploitation une augmentation
de 15% le gouvernement à limiter cette
augmentation à cet ennemi % applicable
au 1er février
alors quand le contrat l'entreprise
comment vont être vos du lait les tarifs
voyageurs et marchandises
je ne peux pas vous dire ce qu'il en
sera dans le contrat d'entreprise est
entendu que ce document n'est pas encore
élaboré il est en cours d'examen en
cours de travail
il est possible que nous bénéficions
d'une liberté tarifaire en ce qui
concerne les marchandises comme je vous
l'indiquais à l'instant en ce qui
concerne les voyageurs les libertés que
nous pourrions obtenir d'andré peut-être
à nous permettre de moduler certains
tarifs notamment en vue de régler ce
problème des pointes de trafic qui
deviennent très difficile du point de
vue technique comme des compagnies
aériennes ont pu le faire avec le
système des tarifs bleu blanc rouge
comme nous mêmes nous l'avons fait avec
les tarifs des trains autos pochette
vous allait supprimer des gars vous
allez supprimer des lignes secondaires
sur quelle base
je ne peux pas vous dire si nous
supprimerons dégâts ou des lignes
secondaires depuis plusieurs années nous
n'avons la sncf n'a supprimé aucune
ligne
le problème du déficit des lignes
omnibus est un véritable problème
puisque l'état chaque année vers 5
milliard et demi de francs lourd pour
compenser les charges financières de ces
lignes omnibus il est possible que
nouvelle organisation ait lieu pour ces
lignes ni bus mais de toute manière le
sort de ces minibus est liée à la
concertation avec les autorités
régionales et locales puisque elles sont
étudiées dans le cadre de schémas
régionaux de transport et il arrive que
des collectivités territoriales
participent financièrement au maintien
ou à l'amélioration de ses dessertes
omnibus bon comme monsieur policière est
un petit peu vague
philippe sassier j'ai envie de vous
poser deux ou trois questions d'abord la
première qui vient à l'esprit est ce la
fin de l'entreprise nationale
non c'est pas la fin des entreprises
nationales mais c'est une modification
profonde des rapports entre l'état la
sncf les charbonnages air france etc
c'est en août 1977 que cette nouvelle
politique était décidée elle se met
petit à petit en place si vous voulez il
n'y a pas un divorce mais c'est un petit
peu comme si un couple
redéfinissez son contrat de mariage et
dans ce nouveau contrat de mariage sous
contrat d'entreprise qu'on l'appelle il
y a deux grandes close la première
l'entreprise à davantage de liberté
c'est-à-dire de souplesse pour fixer
elle même ses tarifs mais l'état garde
un droit de regard un droit de contrôle
et notamment sur ses investissements
l'objectif est bien vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure c'est que ces grandes
entreprises cotées un petit peu moins
cher à la nation
l'an passé l'état dépensé quelques 30
milliards présentent un prix national
alors vous parlez des mariés j'ai envie
de vous parler des enfants c'est-à-dire
des voyageurs première question concrète
pourquoi est ce que les tarifs vont
augmenter
écoutez dans certains cas probablement
puisque si l'état donne moins d'argent
faudra bien que les entreprises en
gagnent davantage notamment en
augmentant leurs tarifs et tout
récemment le ministre des transports
monsieur le theule a déclaré un service
public t pain service gratuit mais
l'état ne veut pas qu'il est d'un seul
coup des augmentations de tarifs trop
grand actuellement les discussions entre
les dirigeants de la sncf et l'état
porte justement sur cette question afin
qu sncf ne fasse pas flamber le billet
de train la sncf qui voulait augmenter
les tarifs voyageurs de 15% et qu'une le
freighter sans cette aide me de cette
année pour cent cette année alors
deuxième question toujours pour
voyageur est ce que la sncf pourra
supprimer des lignes sans s'occuper
ensuite des voyageurs qu'elle ne
transportera passé aussi c'est une
question qui est actuellement débattue
entre l'état et les dirigeants de la
sncf parce que le problème n'est pas
simplement de savoir si les cncf perd de
l'argent mais aussi de savoir si tous
les français même ceux qui sont loin des
grandes villes peuvent être normalement
véhicule est alors vous vous en doutez
c'est un problème politique qui est
intéressant seulement l'état mais les
régions des communes
bref quelques beaux débats en
perspective à l'assemblée nationale et
pour rentabiliser davantage ses dépenses
vous savez travaille depuis longtemps
sur un train de l'avenir le tgv qui
permettra de relier paris à lyon en deux
heures c'est à dire deux fois plus vite
qu'aujourd'hui un train qui fera des
pointes à 260 km heure sur une voie
ferrée toute neuve qui doublera l'ancien
enclos renault a vécu quelques heures
dans le tgv en pleine action
voici le prototype du train à grande
vitesse en gare de strasbourg
oui voitures articulées encadré par deux
automotrices à traction électrique 375
voyageurs pourront y prendre place dont
240 en 2e classe destinée à desservir le
sud est de la france
le tgb empruntera une ligne entièrement
nouvelle qui doublera l'infrastructure
actuelle
arrivé à saturation entre paris et lyon
cette ligne sera presque droite sans
passage à niveau et sans tunnel sur près
de 400 km le train pour a foncé à 260 km
heure un bolide sur rail plus rapide que
le tokaïdo des japonais le conducteur
n'a plus à scruter les bois les signaux
transmis par les rails s'affichent sur
un écran à l'intérieur de la cabine
dans ce train laboratoire tout est
minutieusement vérifiée l'aérodynamisme
la résistance des matériaux l'efficacité
du freinage et caetera et en principe la
vitesse ne sera pas plus cher les
voyageurs du tgv paiera le tarif normal
sans supplément
ce ne sera pas un train de luxe comme on
dit c'est un train ouvert je lise à
l'instant à la première comme à la
deuxième classe et dans des conditions
de confort non connue encore de la 2e
classe au moins équivalente à celle les
voitures corail qui sont climatisées le
tgv le sera aussi
mais le confort du tgv à 260 sera
meilleur que celui des voitures corail
pour une bonne raison
voyez un diagramme de la ram
aucun voyageur ne sera sur un bogie les
sièges sont ici les bogies sont éloignés
on a moins de bruit dans la caisse nous
roulons en ce moment vous l'entendez la
résistance de l'air aussi est plus
faible et la consommation d'énergie de
ce train sera elle aussi réduite
elle sera à 260 celle d'un train
classique roulant à 160 à l'heure des
premiers tgv circuleront en octobre 80
40 % de la population pourront utiliser
ce véritable métro interurbain sur paris
lyon
les rames partiront au rythme d'une
toutes les heures et même toutes les
demi heures en période chargée
le voyageur de deuxième classe arrivera
presqu'aussi vite que le passager d'air
inter est une petite révolution dans les
transports nos dossiers étrangers
maintenant à commencer par l'iran bien
sûr l'iran qu'avec aujourd'hui une
manifestation imposante démonstration de
force de la part de l'ayatollah khomeiny
et la yarra chi religieuse mais qui n'a
pas pour autant fait vaciller le
fauteuil du premier ministre chapour
bakhtiar edouard l'or est à terre
un million deux millions de personnes
peut-être
pour ce vendredi qui aura été la
réplique exacte du mam lundi de
l'achoura y compris sur le parti route
de fréquentes du sang les habitants de
téhéran sans doute presque tous les
habitants de téhéran converger depuis
10h ce matin certains les à la grande
avenue qui traversera cesse en os à 9
heures aresa quinzaine de kilomètres
était noire de monde
noyés dans une perpétuelle rumeurs
s'entremêlaient les slogans mort aux
saints longue vie à communique le tout
aux prix avec autant de vigueur par les
milliers de femmes et d'enfants
j'aurais été tout de même surpris
aujourd'hui par deux jours
avoir pratiquement pas entendu de
slogans hostiles au premier ministre à
kia et avec la ville location qui a
commencé vers midi
semblait beaucoup moins motivés que ces
derniers jours pour autant l'ayatollah
khomeiny a jugé la journée plus que
satisfaisante quand même là y est la ti
aujourd'hui encore n'a pas quitté
neauphle-le-château que nous le pensions
il tarde à regagner l'iran crise
philippe chatenet a vécu à ses côtés
tout au long de la journée
pour l'ayatollah comini et ses partisans
ce soir marque une nouvelle victoire le
déroulement des manifestations
aujourd'hui en iran a été suivie ici
heure par heure et apporte la
confirmation selon l'ayatollah lui même
que le peuple iranien après avoir rejeté
le chat rejeter la succession que ce
dernier avait organisé plus que jamais
aujourd'hui le mot d'ordre de leighton a
commis ni reste intransigeance
aujourd'hui encore il a refusé de
recevoir monsieur seuil est de tehrani
le président du conseil de régence
envoyé spécialement à paris par le
premier ministre pour essayer de
parvenir à un accord avec l'ayatollah la
position de ce dernier reste inflexible
vous appartenez inconsidérés gens ce qui
est illégal at-il fait répondra tehrani
et je ne vous recevrez que quand vous
aurez démissionner
pour l'ayatollah le nouvel iran ne
pourra se construire que lorsque
l'ancien aura été totalement balayé
c'est à dire quand le gouvernement
bakhtiar et le conseil de régence
or en démissionner en fait à ce moment
là l'iran sera placé devant le véritable
choix comme et unis où l'armée et
pendant ce temps le chat lui est
toujours en egypte l'hôte de son ami
anouar al sadate il a rencontré
aujourd'hui l'ancien président américain
gerald ford en vacances dans la région
extrême orient les autorités de hong
kong ont enfin autorisé le et hong a
accosté
voilà près d'un mois que le cargo chargé
de réfugiés vietnamiens et est ancré au
large de la colonie britannique
et puis israël tirs de roquettes il y a
trois heures sur la ville de kiryat
shmona à trois kilomètres de la
frontière libanaise seules deux
personnes ont été légèrement blessées
enfin aujourd'hui pas plus qu'hier
valéry giscard d'estaing n'a pu se
rendre en roumanie le temps vous le
voyez y était beaucoup trop mauvais la
visite est donc définitivement
orthez début mars du 8 au 10 morts à
paris du général challe ce chef
militaire de l'armée de l'air avait été
l'un des quatre organisateurs du putsch
militaire d'alger en 61 avec les
généraux josé l'air et puis un type plus
tard salle en 1 40 euro de quarteron de
généraux en retraite selon l'expression
du charles de gaulle monchal avait 73
ans avec maurice challe disparaît non
seulement le chef mais aussi le plus
jeune des généraux putschistes dont on
voit ici la prise de pouvoir à alger le
22 avril 1961
ancien commandant en chef en algérie ce
résistant dont de gaulle avait fait
l'artisan du démantèlement des maquis
algériens s'étaient juré de garder
l'algérie à la france des opérations sur
le terrain favorable
et voilà pourtant que paris parle d'un
possible état algérien
le retraité volontaire qu'il est alors
décide de rejoindre clandestinement
alger et d'organiser le putsch
la rébellion ne durera que trois jours
arrêté incarcéré et jugé par la cour de
sûreté de l'état
il sera condamné à 15 ans de réclusion à
tulle de gaulle la graciant 66 puis
amnistié en 68 depuis maurice challe
s'étaient expliqués dans ses mémoires
notre révolte et ils étaient celles
d'hommes qui avaient donné leur parole
d'homme et ne pouvait la trahir les
sports maintenant deux ans de suspension
ferme pour le footballeur de rennes
laurent pokou au cours d'un match de
coupe de france il avait donné un coup
de pied à l'arbitré devant cette
sanction le stade rennais refait appel
car si l'appel est rejeté la carrière
professionnelle de pokou sera
vraisemblement terminé le joueur y vas
ivoirien est âgé de trente et un
football toujours gros souffle
les licenciés du stade de reims qui
viennent déposer vous savez son bilan ne
seront indemnisés cac 40 % en effet ne
sont pas considérés par les assedic
comme des licenciés économiques
et puis le ski ski chez les dames qui se
retrouvaient ce matin à meiringen pour
disputer le slalom spécial la victoire
est revenue sans grande surprise à
l'autrichien à gina sakho
devant l'italienne claudia jordanie la
première française fabienne serra se
place à la 8e place
mais pour daniel de bernard que voici
victime d'une chute dans la première
manche vous allez le voir
la saison est terminée en effet daniel
de bernard souffre d'une fracture de la
cheville et à 24 ans il semble même que
sa carrière soit compromise daniel de
berne
rugby j'avais que dans moins de 20
heures maintenant le départ du tournoi
des cinq nations la france qui
affrontera l'irlande au stade de
lansdowne road est arrivé hier à dublin
ça nous promet un beau festival de
couleurs d'un côté les tricolores en
face ces diables verts d'anglais
d'irlande n tous unis pour manger du
fruit c'est à dire ces mangeurs de
grenouilles que nous sommes
dublin un peuple de la capitale dans la
nuit qui n'en finit pas la jeunesse
irlandaise malades du chômage nous à son
désoeuvrement dans la bière est dans le
champ
plus
à 200 km de là dans le nord de l'île
belfast déchiré par la guerre civile ne
parvient plus à cacher sa misère partout
dans le pays
l'homme de la rue ressent cette
partition de l'irlande comme une maladie
honteuse
en attendant le tournoi des six nations
qui chaque année le temps d'un match
créé le miracle de la réconciliation
nationale
c'est ici à lansdowne road qu'irlandais
du sud et irlandais d'une heure oublient
leurs vieilles querelles sur le dos de
leurs adversaires pour faire la paix des
braves
symbole de cette union sacrée par le
rugby mike gibson ici à l'entraînement
dans son maillot rayé un numéro 21
aussi populaire à belfast où il est né
qu'à dublin où il a porté pendant 14 ans
le maillot vert de l'irlande
républicaine situation ambiguë dans un
pays où choisir son camp est une
nécessité
la plus un bon sentiment personnel c'est
que je représente l'irlande une je
respecte le pouvoir d'une fédération qui
a autorité dans l'ensemble du pays
moi le nord 10 lorsque je suis à dublin
j'observe les traditions du sud et je
reconnais ligne de ce pays enfin mike
gibson ayant renoncé à jouer contre la
france pour cause de retraite
internationale c'est donc fergus
slattery
le baroudeur qui devient l'image de
marque du rugby irlandais réunis en
séminaire pour la première fois de son
histoire le quinze de france est ce
pionner le jeu de ses adversaires en
regardant à la télé le match irlande
all-blacks pour s'imprégner de ce fameux
esprit de combat qui fait dit-on la
force du nouveau patron de l'équipe
d'irlande
je crois que faire du château ya
vraiment là la démonstration à cet
esprit chaque fois qu'un de ses
camarades est blessé ou un peu un peu
fatigué il lui dit en anglais font la
fierté en nous sommes là pour quelque
chose il faut vraiment faire le maximum
pour notre maillot et je crois que
chaque fois une démonstration de courage
exceptionnel dans ces conditions le
match contre l'irlande a valeur de test
pour le rugby français
après avoir perdu la saison dernière
jacques fouroux le capitaine du grand
chelem
le quinze de france a perdu cette année
jean-claude skréla son meilleur joueur
dur handicap pour un groupe qui n'en
finit pas de chercher sa personnalité
pour donner un moral tout neuf à cette
équipe de france qui peut gagner tous
ses matches comme elle peut les perdre
tous le stage qui s'est tenue ce
week-end à bordeaux et que les
britanniques appellent le squat système
était le bienvenu une bonne occasion en
effet de se forger une motivation
le fighting spirit comme on dit en
irlande un mot barbare qui
n'impressionne pas gérard cholley le dur
de l'équipe de france on parle beaucoup
de fighting spirit à leur propos alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire vous savez
moi et l'anglais à part nos problèmes
c'est tout je suis mais on verra bien
rendez vous donc demain à 15 heures 50
avec colère et couderc et balla sur
rente end le temps après un petit peu de
verglas du matin redou dans l'après midi
vous le voyez les températures vont
remonter assez rapidement demain et bien
sûr douce se poursuivra sur l'ensemble
du pays
quelques gelées sur le nord et l'est
chutes de neige possibles quand même
ailleurs le temps sera le plus souvent
couvert avec de la pluie
les rendez vous de l'information sur
antenne 2 22h40 le dernier journal
présenté ce soir par pierre alain et
puis demain samedi et demi avec paul
lefèvre merci de votre attention
merci au nom de toute l'équipe qui m'a
aidé à composer ce journal excellente
cette semaine à lundi